OK, I got a voicemail.
Which raises a very relevant question.
I think the voicemail number, which you can
call anytime of day, is two one nine two.
David excuse me.
David P..
Got a little too excited here.
Let's take a listen to this voicemail.
Hi, David.
This is Jacob from Denver, Colorado.
Hey, quick question about your video on from
being divorced from reality.
I just watched it.
And it makes me wonder, do you think that
room is lying or do you think that everybody
around him is lying to him saying, hey, he's
winning all of these states?
The polls are looking gray and these polls
that the public sees are actually suppression
polls or whatever it is he calls them.
So I was wondering, what's your take on that?
Yeah.
This is a really good question.
Now, there's a third possibility here, which
I'm going to raise in a moment, which has
actually been suggested by some of the people
around Donald Trump.
So when Trump comes out and he says we're
winning in Florida and Florida, he thinks
he's winning both.
We're winning in, you know, all these states
that every poll says he's losing.
And does Trump know he's lying or is someone
coming to him and saying, Mr. President, you're
actually winning in Florida?
And Trump just repeats it.
There's a third possibility, which is that
Trump's memory is gone.
And he genuinely has no recollection of this
stuff because some of these kind of insider
tell all books that have been written about
Donald Trump claim that advisers are shocked
by how Trump's memory is gone.
Trump will say something one day and then
a few days later, he will deny ever having
said it.
And we from the outside wonder, is he lying?
Is he gaslighting?
And the third possibility, of course.
Or is he being lied to?
The third possibility is he's just forgotten.
And I don't know the answer when I hear Trump
come out and say we have the lowest death
rate in the world.
We actually have, you know, the ninth highest
deaths per capita on Corona.
Even our case fatality rate isn't the lower.
Like, there's no measure by which were the
best on death rate.
Does Trump.
No, that that's not true, and he's lying.
Is someone coming to Trump and telling him
that?
And he's the one being lied to and he doesn't
know any better?
Or has Trump just forgotten?
I don't know the answer.
I genuinely have no idea which it is.
If I had to venture a guess in different instances,
it's a different combination.
I think in some cases Trump is just lying.
I think in other cases, Trump is probably
being shielded from less than optimal realities
by the people around him.
And in some cases, Trump genuinely does seem
to just forget things.
So I think it's probably a combination of
the three.
Let me know what you think on the bonus show
today.
We will be talking about we already have one
baseball team that has bailed on the season
were days in because of a corona virus outbreak.
We'll talk about what we know.
We'll talk about what we expect.
We'll talk about could this possibly be contained?
Now that it is in the Major League Baseball
system.
Number two, why is there a coin shortage in
the United States, not paper currency, but
coins?
Why is there a coin shortage?
We will talk about that.
And number three up police agencies are making
some police agencies are making a big deal
of saying they don't want to provide security
at the Democratic National Convention.
Why is this happening?
Is it political posturing?
Is there a bigger political movement behind
it?
What forces are supporting this being done?
All of these stories and more we will be talking
about today on The David Pakman Show bonus
show.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show.
No.
One, become a member.
Join Pacman dot com.
No, to become a patron at Patrie on dot com
slash David Pakman show.
Either one gets you instant access.
You will probably be able to join me for a
livestream later today if you're following
my training for the upcoming POG Champs to
Chess Tournament.
I recently had another lesson with international
master Lévy.
Rosemann will be posting that to YouTube soon.
I also have upcoming lessons in the works
with Alexandra Boats has and Eric Rosen.
So if you're looking for a break from the
politics, there's plenty of nonpolitical content
available for you.
But of course, these streams related to politics
will continue.
I've also been asked to start streaming, Joe,
by Joe Biden, who started doing press conferences.
I've been asked to start streaming them.
I think it's important to do so.
And we're going to try to work that into the
schedule as well.
So much happening and I will see you either
on the bonus show or on a livestream or tomorrow